[SPEAKER_02]: Second of Wales, son, after Jude, Paul, and the Marines have been ambushed on the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jude and Paul rejoin the unit to discuss what's next.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you guys run up to the sergeant, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And he says to you,
[SPEAKER_02]: We've killed these creatures.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he actually kicks one of the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what's strange about this hobgoblin is that the armor and weaponry that he's wearing is actually very similar to what Sea Principality Marines wear as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, it's a little different.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not as if it was from another Commodore.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's as if
[SPEAKER_02]: The people that construct this stuff are the same.
[SPEAKER_02]: These items, however, were made a little bit differently to signify different kinds of units, strangely enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, these hobgoblins are humanoids.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're not human.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just say, they're corrupted moraines.
[SPEAKER_01]: I kick one of them.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to push into the Citadel.
[SPEAKER_02]: You say we've got to push into the Citadel?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and you ask for a potion of healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: The sergeant says, I don't see how we can do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look!
[SPEAKER_02]: And he points up the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there a horrible understanding there?
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, what it is, is there's a column.
[SPEAKER_02]: of what looks to be like 50 guys coming down the hill from the Citadel towards you, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And the sergeant kind of looks up over at Paul and he says, the prince, he's wounded.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to get him to safety.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, how far up this is the Column?
[SPEAKER_01]: If the Column wanted to rush us, is it like two rounds away?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's not going to be possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see it marching from a ways.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's probably, I would say... Half a mile?
[SPEAKER_01]: Quarter a mile?
[SPEAKER_02]: More like a quarter mile.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they're coming down out of the...
[SPEAKER_01]: So we can just see that we're totally outnumbered.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any possible chance we can group up with the other first and second squad?
[SPEAKER_01]: Our best chance would be to take the squad with us and fight our way to the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, we could- I don't know about that because- Okay, look, let me double check, but I don't think I have- We need to move.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to find cover.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where shall we go?
[SPEAKER_02]: The barracks are over there and he points over to where the barracks are and you can see it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's probably a thousand feet away as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are walls, Palisade walls and so on there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe there's some troops there that we can free or liberate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep your troops ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep your crossbowmen ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says there could be enemy there as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you guys start marching in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I tell you, I say stay back, and I will lead with the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically, you guys... Well, do you allow for bandaging, or do we have to have medic skill?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can bandage, and that helps, but you guys have to understand that there's a thing called a short rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which, if you find a cover, you can rest for an hour.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we can get to the barracks, we might be able to short rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: So no one's got a potion in him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not a main barrel.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm a battle maker.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, and you're like the nephew of Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why aren't you like having a couple of those up your ass?
[SPEAKER_01]: All you gotta do is like squish your butt, create your butt and like flex it.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why I never sit down.
[SPEAKER_02]: So by the way, only money falls out.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, all right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're gonna, we're gonna follow what the Sarge said, and what I am desperately hoping is that they're using...
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, didn't somebody do that in our group?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sorry, I think somebody did where they took a potion of evil.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to ask.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I remembered it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just remember they were all like, hey, you can stick it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, whatever damage you do gets healed instantly.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're like, oh, he's got hemorrhoids.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's bleeding.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nope, he's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm actually hoping though is, and I will verbally say this out loud as we're booking towards the barrack, is I'll say, be prepared.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there's guards on the barracks, our only hope is that there's soldiers there.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But be prepared if there's guards in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crossbow men,
[SPEAKER_01]: We are, as we present.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in classic wedge, with the shield guys in front, same way we did it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we gotta go up and it's over here, or if it's over here...
[SPEAKER_02]: It's over this way.
[SPEAKER_02]: The helm is up that way, up the road.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where is Gouge and his 30 guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: Way over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least we would be like... And in fact, I do have a mount of Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will send that map to you so you can kind of get the idea of what the layout looks like.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so you guys march towards the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I wouldn't say march.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say we run in formation.
[SPEAKER_02]: You quickly march towards the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a route.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not a route, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you go.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not a route.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say this march takes you about 10 minutes as it is, you know, maybe about a quarter mile away from where you are now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: As you're going, you see the unit from the helm march down the hill towards the docks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, like they're ignoring us?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's obvious that what they're doing is going to aid whatever is happening down there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you are heading towards the barracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I give him the invisibility ring.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of Lord of the Rings.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fuck off.
[SPEAKER_01]: It ain't Lord of the Rings.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you don't have to give him the invisibility ring.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can cast invisibility.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cast it on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that would only be if I had it actually done and I actually don't have invisibility.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you're saying with the ring.
[SPEAKER_01]: It gives you the spell invisibility.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can cast it.
[SPEAKER_01]: On whoever I want.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you have to recharge it with the second level spell slot after you've used the charge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so what I tell you is I'm going to cast you as invisible.
[SPEAKER_01]: As we're, you know, moving quickly with our troops.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm like, I can't heal you, but I can make you invisible.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't attack or it will break the invisibility unless you absolutely, like, have to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, cast a spell on you, you're no longer a team.
[SPEAKER_01]: But at least the troops still see me and the Sarge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine, because he was hiding under the dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys move to the Citadel, reaching it within 10 minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get to the Citadel, and the sergeant says, stay here, when you're about 600 feet from the opening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just me.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's...
[SPEAKER_02]: He's back behind.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I'm talking about the entire units, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he steps forward and says, who holds this?
[SPEAKER_02]: And he goes, give me the key word.
[SPEAKER_02]: You hear from one of the towers up on the thing, this barracks is still held by the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Does the sergeant say anything?
[SPEAKER_02]: The sergeant goes,
[SPEAKER_02]: My key word is, on the honor of John.
[SPEAKER_02]: The guard says, on the honor of fairwind.
[SPEAKER_02]: The guard says that.
[SPEAKER_02]: The sergeant kind of looks at you and says to Jude, that is the password.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so let us in and we move quickly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the units start to move towards there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, because up to now it's been sea creatures and hobgoblins that have been fighting us.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm going to assume that Lord Fairwind got overwhelmed by whatever stealth methods, but that he's not the enemy.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's my assumption.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys march into the thing, or scramble into the thing, and all these other guards come out to basically help you guys into the area.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, we need a healer!
[SPEAKER_02]: These are Sea Principalities' Pali guys, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you say, we need a healer.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, for all the guys, not just the, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so basically you come in, and the sergeant connects to the garrison commander, and the garrison commander goes, so, you're the relief.
[SPEAKER_02]: We've been under attack ever since that strange fog covered the island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quickly, come in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bring your wounded.
Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we bring the wounded in, and we have his abilities to dissipate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, only if you're going to interact and have... Yeah, well, no, which is fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, if they have a dealer, you need to get healed, for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, basically, the guards come in and...
[SPEAKER_02]: Luckily, you see that a lot of the garrison is still here.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are many men here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So of 100 garrison, maybe 50, 70?
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks like these guys have not been molested as far as attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: But what percentage?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I just guess?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, I think that's better in...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know what I'm saying?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the commander of the garrison takes you guys into a place.
[SPEAKER_02]: The men basically go to the barracks to rest and do whatnot.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it looks like there are guards on all the stations, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And places seems to be well defended still.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only reason why I'm asking is because I'm trying to do a quick assessment on if we can help the captain and the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like if we need to make a foray out.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we're only talking about like proportionally, let's say we don't know about any other defensive position.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know what you're doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm saying that you don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm saying that even if you had a hundred men- There's a lot of able-bodied men, but we- There's a lot of able-bodied men, and doing the foray, you don't know how many you need to be able to do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'd have to see what the enemy was up to to be able to decide what was going to happen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, and 200 guys were outnumbered.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, they're five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably five.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know what that means?
[SPEAKER_02]: That means we've got to get a signal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, before you guys start talking, you guys go into the barracks area, and you're there with the sergeant, the garrison commander, and then the two of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And do you want to expose yourself and basically say who you are?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I may as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so.